[Musique]
bonjour bonjour à tous filecho c'est
votre grand rendez-vous chcho sur TVfil
78 toute l'actualité économique de votre
territoire et de la région aujourd'hui
un numéro sportif et festif tout de
suite le sommaire
50 ans Enel terre de sport ce n'est pas
juste un slogan tout est fait pour il y
a le cadre évidemment il y a aussi ses
équipements exceptionnels un Vélodrome
et un golf national et les compétitions
qui vont avec bien sûr dernière en date
l'Open de France 100e édition nous y
étions et en attendant la rider Cup de
golf en 2018 et pourquoi pas les Jeux
Olympiques en 2024
50 anine abrite aussi la plus grande île
de loisirs d'île-de-fance et des parcs
comme France Miniature quel impact
économique pour c-quentin en Yveline on
en parle avec nos invités bonjour Huc
jarot bonjour vous êtes directeur
général du Vélodrome national alors
c'est le temple du cyclisme mais pas
seulement vous allez nous expliquer
pourquoi Marie-Hélène Carabantes alors
vous êtes la directrice de l'île de
loisirs de Saint-Quentin en Yveline qui
comme son nom indique est un lieu dédié
au loisirs mais aussi au sport et vous
avez des liens des relations avec les
entreprises merci d'être avec nous
bonjour et enfin Arnaud sor vous êtes
directeur général de fitness Academy
alors vous vous proposez des salles de
sport clé en main aux entreprises c'est
ça exactement un secteur en pointe
absolument et en plus vous êtes
extrêmement bien placé ici à sa-quentin
en Eveline et là aussi vous allez nous
expliquer pourquoi dans un instant donc
merci à vous trois d'être avec nous
merci de participer à ce filcho sportif
et festif je le rappelle tout de suite
le chiffre du mois et ce chiffre c'est
380000 380000 sportifs licenciés dans le
département des Yvelines le premier
département d'Île-de- France et le 4e de
France par le nombre de licenciés toutes
les disciplines sportives il sont
représenté enfin vous le savez nous
faisons le point sur l'actualité
économique de votre territoire dans
filcho c'est les temps forts de de la
semaine avec Fanny Bourdillon on voit
[Musique]
ça le mois de juin aura été marqué par
les intempéries qui ont ravagé le
département de saint-rémis les
chevreuses à rambouillé en passant par
poissi peu de villes auront été
épargnées en première ligne les
transports en commun ont connu de
grandes difficultés Valérie PCR la
présidente de région a débloqué un fond
d'urgence d'un million d'euros pour
venir en aide aux plus petites communes
les villes qui sont touchés par les
intempéries sont de taille très
variables c'est pour ça que la Région a
décidé de mettre en place un fond
d'urgence d'un million d'euros qui va
être déclenché dès cet après-midi de
façon à ce que les petits villages ceux
qui ne savent pas bien comment se
dépatouiller dans les dans dans toutes
les contraintes administratives de la
déclaration de catastrophe naturelle et
cetera puis puisse très très vite
enclencher la dynamique des travaux de
réparation parmi les plus sinistrés on
compte les agriculteurs de la région à
vernouiller cet agriculteur a vu 30 de
ces hectares inondés il estime son
préjudice à 500000 €. moi j'ai évoqué
éventuellement le dépôt de bilan
première solution c'est un outil de
gestion pour éventuellement redémarrer
soit c'est une cessation d'activité ou
soit G relancer avec le concours je
dirais de l'État si l'état nous amène
des mesurettes comme jai comme
d'habitude parce qu'on les connaît les
recettes il les ressortent les mêmes
c'est pas une solution l'autre actualité
de ce mois de juin c'est évidemment le
brexit les Britanniques ont dit non à
l'Union européenne à 52 %. quelques
semaines après le vote l'impact sur
l'Europe reste incertain quelle
conséquence pour notre territoire pour
l'entreprise IP software basée à Montini
le Bretonneux la chute de la livre
sterling pourrait avoir des conséquences
sur leur activité on verra après dans un
en fonction de l'évolution
tout
simplement de la livre si on doit nous
augmenter notre tarification ou pas mais
on sera malheureusement obligé aussi en
tout état de cause de tenir compte de
nos concurrents sur place pour faire en
sorte que notre offre reste
effectivement compétitive inquiétude
aussi du côté des politiques nous avons
reçu en plateau Pierre Lequiller
conseiller régional et président de
l'association Île-de France Europe nous
lui avons demandé si l'Europe allait
perdre beaucoup avec le départ du
Royaume-Uni écoutez sa réponse c'est
très difficile de répondre aujourd'hui
c'est très difficile de répondre
aujourd'hui je pense pour dire la vérité
que l'Angleterre va plus perdre que que
que l'Europe sur le plan économique
c'est dramatique il y a plein
d'entreprises qui qui sont déjà en train
d'envisager de déménager à à Paris ou à
Francfort notamment dans le domaine
financier il y a déjà des des des des
dispositions qui sont
[Musique]
prises voilà pour l'essentiel de
l'actualité économique du mois
l'essentiel de l'actualité de votre
territoire on en vient à notre thème le
thème de ce filcho le sport le loisir
autant de vecteurs pour booster muscler
j'ose dire l'actualité enfin pas
l'actualité l'économie de votre
territoire on dit souvent que 50 an
yeline est un terrain de sport à ciel
ouvert est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
est-ce que c'est à le slogan ou c'est ce
que c'est une réalité Aro non c'est vrai
en fait nous enfin je vois notre notre
équipement permet d'accueillir plein
plein de sports différents que ce soit
de la piste forcément en fait mais on a
permis aussi de développer d'autres
activités au milieu donc on a du
badminton on a de la box on a bientôt du
judo et on est très proche du comment du
du Golf National donc aujourd'hui c'est
vrai que c'est un vrai territoire où on
peut vraiment faire beaucoup d'activités
sportives que ce soit au niveau amateur
au niveau professionnel en fait ARN vous
partagez aussi cette cette analyse
alors moi je me place sur un plan plus
entreprise c'est vrai que le territoire
est très dynamique en terme
d'implantation de grandes entreprises et
notre terrain de jeu est ici donc nous
installons des salles de fitness en
entreprise sur le territoire c'est vrai
qu'il y a beaucoup beaucoup de demande
les gens ont besoin d'acquérir des
talents en entreprise de les faire venir
sur le territoire de 550 aneline après
leur formation et surtout de les garder
parce qu'après elles deviennent amoureux
du territoire et avec des installations
de cette qualité c'est c'est un vrai
plus et avec une base de loisirs comme
celle que vous gérez là aussi c'est
c'est important
comme vecteur économique oui oui tout à
fait et là en plus nous sommes en
complémentarité hein donc effectivement
à ciel ouvert effectivement nous offrons
effectivement toutes les
activités de de de loisirs en plein air
un sport en plein air donc en
complémentarité avec effectivement le
vélodrome donc que ce soit centre un
centre nautique des activités nautiques
que ce soit centre équestre voilà donc
toutes ces activités viennent en
complémentarité de de ce qui qui est
proposé aujourd'hui sur sur le
territoire voilà il y a des synergies
des synergies entre vous tous donc on y
reviendra tout au long de cette émission
voilà on l'a dit c'est pas un simple
slogan
50 ans en Yveline terre de sport on va
voir quelques images d'un d'un événement
qui s'est passé il y a quelques semaines
seulement un évenement important l'Open
de France de golf c'était la 100e
édition alors l'épreuve s'est disputé
sur le parcours de l'Albatros au Golf
National de Guy encour et c'est vrai que
là aussi on voit que la compétition elle
est sur le green é évidemment mais aussi
dans le village des entreprises parce
qu'il y a un village des entreprises
très important et Fanny Bourdillon a
voulu savoir pourquoi les entreprises se
placer les marques surtout vous allez
voir que c'est important de participer à
ce genre d'événement pour des marques
très très renommées
regardez l'Open de France est une
compétition sportive mondialement connue
mais le tournoi est aussi une vitrine
commerciale pour de nombreuses marque
pendant 4 jours un village d'entreprise
s'est installé entre les Green les
places sont chères pour installer un St
attende mais l'investissement ne
décourage pas les sociétés le tarif de
base c'est 3000 € en fait pour exposer
et puis ça monte justement sur le
texting Center une placeer à la boutique
ça monte à peu près jusqu'au 6000 € donc
voilà c'est des tarifs pour pour exposer
et après bah ce que ça représente pour
une entreprise c'est aujourd'hui le plus
grand événement golf en France c'est la
référence on va dire les entreprises les
marques bah c'est l'événement
incontournable aujourd'hui pour
rencontrer 50000 golfur c'est ici qu'il
faut être pour cette 100e édition le
village s'est agrandi pour accueillir 60
exposants ici à la boutique du golf la
compétition et surtout la venue de Rory
mckilroy permet de booster leur chiffre
d'affaires pourquoi avoir une tente tout
d'abord pour faire pour faire du
business très clairement après on est
ici aussi dans cet espace pour
représenter l'Open de France et aussi la
rider Cup qui va se jouer en 2018 pour
d'autres partenaires l'Open de golf
c'est aussi l'occasion de développer
leur image de marque c'est le cas de BMW
pour nous c'est important de de proposer
différentes choses donc c'est les 100
ans de la marque cette année donc pour
ces 100 ans on a amené des véhicules
historiques on a présenté on a deux
véhicules historiques qu'on a ramené du
musée de Munich on a également des
voitures plus modernes et en plus de ça
on a une boutique lifestyle où on
présente n nos produits donc lifestyle
golf et également donc cette fameuse
voiture sur l'eau la i8 rouge et qui est
pour la première fois présentée en
France dans dans cette couleur des
partenariats qui peuvent rapporter gros
aux sociétés c'est si ces dernières ne
souhaitent pas communiquer sur leur
chiffre d'affaires elles sont 85 %
chaque année à renouveler leur
partenariat avec l'Open de France de
golf donc on vient de le voir à sport et
business de mots qui vont bien ensemble
alors HUG jarot vous votre prochain
grand rendez-vous c'est les championnats
d'Europe de cyclisme c'est ça c'est à
partir du 19 octobre 23 tout à fait ouis
voilà alors là aussi quelle retombée en
fait économique est-ce que là aussi les
entreprises sont très présentes
qu'est-ce que ça peut apporter
financièrement au territoire ben écoutez
déjà tout d'abord une visibilité en fait
c'est clair que ce type d'événement que
soit championnat d'Europe ou championnat
du monde comme ça a eu lieu au mois de
mars dernier en fait on a une visibilité
mondiale avec la télévision on a
beaucoup de là on a la recherche de
partenaires sur le territoire pour qu'il
soit aussi visible tout autour on le
voit sur les images on tout autour de la
piste en fait et tous ces S sont
retransmis donc on travaille là-dessus
après il y a beaucoup d'offres
d'hospitalité ça permet aussi de
permettre aux entreprises d'inviter
leurs clients ou bien de de de faire la
communication avec d'autres sociétés en
fait donc on va mettre en place de
l'hospitalité ça sera au cœur du
Vélodrome dans l'air centrale en bas à
côté des des comment des des cyclistes
en fait on pourra en fait des courants
on pourra déjeuner ou dîner en fait
pendant le pendant les championnats
d'Europe et il a aussi après une partie
hospitalité dans les salons supérieurs
où là on a des accès en fait dans les
tribunes et aussi des salons pour
pouvoir communiquer inviter ses clients
et c'est vraiment important pour nous ça
permet de changer un peu du du football
du rugby ou de Roland garot ce type de
chos en fait le sport en fait le format
court du vélo et intéressant parce que
les courses sont rapides on peut s'inter
assez rapidement et ça ça ça ça donne
beaucoup de rythme en fait donc c'est ce
que les gens recherchent et en fait
c'est vraiment d'abord de la
communication c'est-à-dire comme vous
dites une marque c'està 50 ans neline
c'est le cyclisme voilà c'est c'est pour
donner un voilà une autre image oui
enfin c'est saentin c'est pas que le
cyclisme on vient de le voir avec le
golf en fait mais c'est le cyclisme sur
PIST c'est aussi le BMX on a la la seule
piste couverte de BMX en France en fait
et comment les athlètes peuvent
s'entraîner d' là ils sont en train de
s'entraîner pour les Jeux olympiques de
Rio on a aussi envie de développer autre
chose que le que le cycliste sur P sont
sur route on voudrait pouvoir proposer
des vélos de route pour aller rouler en
Vallet de Chevreuse ou aussi des comment
des VTT pour aller rouler sur les
futures Colin deslancour qui sera aussi
le site pour les Jeux Olympiques de 2024
donc on voudrait pouvoir que le
vélodrome soit vraiment le centre du
vélo avec la présence de la FFC et
permettre aussi de développer toutes les
activités à côté en fait donc et que les
gens puissent nous on travaille beaucoup
avec les sociétés pour des séminaires
donc elles viennent pour faire leur leur
comment leur leur le leur présentation
annuelle ou ce type de chose mais après
on leur fournit des activités sportives
avec nous la base de loisir donc voilà
ça on va y revenir aussi mais peut-être
un mot vous l'avez dit il y a le il y a
le cyclisme certes il y a le golf
évidemment avec la rider Cup qui a
attendu en 2018 c'est quand même un
événement mythique Saint-Quentin eneline
va devenir le centre du monde de la du
golf donc là on va on va yevenenir avec
vous plus je crois que l'événement est
sui par plusieurs millions je ne crois
pas par plusieurs millions de
téléspectateurs donc c'est très
important mais j'ai envie de dire alors
on va y revenir avec vous dans un
instant mais pour vous est-ce que ça a
des retombées est-ce que c'est voilà il
y a un événement international qui se
passe ici même euh la base de loisir
peut-elle en profiter vous Arnaud sur
est-ce que vous pouvez en profiter on
commence avec vous marie-eleline
caravantè ah c'est un événement à ne pas
rater enfin il faut qu'on soit présent
et on espère aujourd'hui réouvrir
pouvoir réouvrir le camping pour cet
événement et être une proposition en
terme d'hôellerie pour tout le public
qui va venir en masse sur ces sur ces
quelques jours donc c'est important
effectivement que l'île de loisirs de 50
ans en ieline puisse être présente
également sur cet événement de cette
manière-là mais pas que parce que
effectivement on y propose également
d'autres activités donc c'est un moyen
effectivement de faire découvrir toutes
les activités proposées par l'île de
loisir mais c'est facile de rentrer en
contact avec les organisateurs de la
rider Cup de leur dire voilà nous on est
là on peut aussi vous proposer des des
partenariats c'est facile ou pas alors
effectivement il y a l'aspect camping
hébergement et puis nous avons également
un golf sur l'île de loisir et nous
espérons bien effectivement que dans le
cadre de la rider Cup un événement
puisse être organiser faire venir des
têtes d'affiches et organiser une
compétition d'accord il faut mettre ça
en place alors avur vous est-ce que si
vous pouvez bénéficier d'un événement
comme la rider Cup alors en fait tous
les événements sont bon à prendre tout
ce qui se passe vraiment sur le
territoire c'est fantastique ça crée une
dynamique entrepreneuial c'estd que même
au sein des organisations les gens ont
plus envie de se bouger c'est qu'on
vient pas uniquement pour occuper son
bureau travail du matin au soir mais ça
crée des liens dans les discussions même
dans les actions que tout à l'heure vous
avez montré le nombre de licenciés mais
en fait hors licence il y a énormément
de gens qui font du sport sur le
territoire qui mettent simplement leur
basket et qui qui vont courir le midi on
a des espaces fantastiques pour ça bien
sur la base de loisirs mais les étants
de la minière sont vraiment juste ici
donc ças vraiment une dynamique en
entreprise et nous et bien comme nous
gérons plusieurs entreprises sur le
territoire on participe à cette
dynamique aussi pour leur entraînement
donc après ben ils sont peut-être
golfeurs amateurs mais ils vont se
mettre à s'entraîner physiquement pour
être plus performant ils sont peut-être
cyclistes amateurs mais ils vont là
aussi se mettre à une préparation plus
sérieuse ou une alimentation plus
sérieuse pour être à la fois plus
performant être dans le mouvement voà
c'est une quête de sens général vers non
plus uniquement le business mais le
business et aussi je me sens bien dans
ma vie et dans mon corps alorsar vous
vous avez déjà pensé à des des
événements en parallèle avec la rider
Cup c'estàdire que en fait là il y a des
synergies entre le Vélodrome et et le
Golf National tout à fait en fait on va
déjà commencer l'année prochaine avec le
pine de France en fait on je pense qu'on
va justement vous AZ montrer le village
on va peut-être prendre un stand pour
développer ETF présenter le le Vélodrome
c'est que toutes toutes ces personnes
qui seront là en journée pour suivre
l'Open de France ou après la rider Cup
le soir elles vont rester sur le
territoire l'idée c'est que nous on est
ouvert très tard en fait on pe même
ouvert plus tard c'est capter cette
population et les faire venir sur le
vélodrome pour faire des baptêmes pour
tester la piste en plus il y aura une
grande population anglo-saxon qui est
vraiment fan de de cyclisme sur piste
même sur de BMX donc on a vraiment envie
de faire en sorte il un projet AC la
communauté de Saint-Quentin en fait de
peut-être de changer l'air centrale du
Vélodrome et faire un trou en un où on
appelle ça un trou du diable pour que
les gens puissent venir en fait se
tester en fait dans le vedr mais en même
temps essayer de les capter pour qu'ils
puisse faire faire des des baptêms de
piste nous on a prévu de bloquer tous
les baptêmes du soir entre 18h et 22h
voir minuit pour que les gens puissent
venir et pouvoir accueillir tout ce
public pour les initier en fait mais la
plupart sont déjà fans donc j'espère que
avec les événements qu'on train de faire
les championnats d'Europe et d'autres
événements anglo-saxons qui vont venir
sur le terra au Vélodrome on puisse
capter cette population il puisse venir
et savoir queil y a un Vélodrome et
queils peuvent venir rouler autant
qu'ils veulent alors la raille d' Cup
c'est acté ça sera en 2018 hein là il y
a pas de souci euh on pense tous aux
Jeux olympiques de 2024 si si Paris
décroche donc enfin voilà si elle
décroche ses Jeux Olympiques là aussi
j'imagine que vous avez des synergies
qui seront importantes enfin c'est un
lieu qui ça va être un lieu important 50
an ivline ah oui c'est clair bah nous on
va accueillir en fait la piste le
cyclisme sur piste et le BMX donc
aujourd'hui on travaille déjà avec les
architectes du projet euh français en
fait pour la la candidature ils sont
venus visiter il y a un mois en fait le
site son en train de travailler sur des
sur des visuels en fait du site pour
2024 qui doivent présenter je crois là
au joio de de Rio donc on est déjà
dedans on a déjà fait les premières
réunions et on avance dessus voilà oui
effectivement il y a les épreuves desrib
aussi et du pintatelon moderne je crois
qu' pourrait aussi toutou c'est ou voilà
exactement et vous alors vous aussi
j'imagine bon c'est une évidence les
Jeux Olympiques c'est toujours un espoir
de retombé économiqu pour vous aussi
c'est c'est le cas c'est ce que vous
pensezou évidemment avec la proximité
d'autant plus du Vélodrome nous ouvrons
nos nos porte pour l'organisation
effectivement de cet événement et nous
mettrons tout en œuvre pour que
effectivement proposer activité voilà au
public qui viendra donc voilà on va
croiser les doigts pour 2024 arnur on va
sortir de ces grands événements sportifs
hein vous l'avez dit ça entraîn une
dynamique et moi j'aimerais un peu plus
comprendre ce que vous faites parce que
fitness Academy en fait ça ça propose
aux entreprises des salles de sport clé
en main et c'est un secteur en pointe
vous avez pu le constater vous vous êtes
un enfant d'ici et en fait c'est c'était
bien c'était bien vu puisque en fait
vous avez trouvé sur le territoire votre
votre activité c'est ça bien en fait moi
je suis arrivé sur le territoire
effectivement il y a 34 ans ça commence
à faire un petit peu et j'ai fait toutes
mes études à en cours mais par contre je
suis devenu entrepreneur bien plus tard
une fois que j'ai eu mon titre de
champion du monde de fitness donc ça
fait là aussi quelques années en arrière
et j'ai apporté cette valeur ajoutée sur
le territoire de d'amener une perfection
dans la formation des coach sportifs et
donc cette formation de coach sportifs
que je voulais vraiment de haut niveau
avec une exigence tant sur les
savoir-faire que sur les savoir-être et
bien maintenant je l'emmène jusqu'au
cœur des organisations donc dans les
grandes dans les grandes sociétés je
place des coachs qui ont été formés par
fitness Academy bien sûr et surtout
j'apporte un gage de de tenue de rigueur
et d'encadrement de vraiment au niveau
donc des grandes grandes entreprises du
secteur en profitent et j'en suis très
heureux c'est un secteur en pointe vous
avez pu constater alors c'est vraiment
un secteur qui est en pleine explosion
parce que les entreprises effectivement
sont en concurrence donc quelqu'un qui
sort ingénieur par exemple et bien quand
il va choisir sa société bien sûr il y a
un aspect rémunération qui rentre en jeu
mais pas que il y a combien est-ce que
je seraiis payé mais où est-ce que je
vais vivre donc sur quel territoire
est-ce que ce territoire est attractif
et puis que me propose la société pour
que je sois bien donc le bien-être en
entreprise et tout tout ce tous les
risques psychosociaux que l'on cherche à
éliminer ou en tout cas à réduire au
maximum c'est vraiment dans l'air du
temps absolument et on le combat par
l'activité sportif alors filcho c'est
une émission chcho est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire un peu combien les
entreprises sont prêtes à mettre pour
pour entretenir le moral le bien-être de
leur de leurs salariés de leurs employés
alors en terme de chiffre d'affaires
nous on c'est en fonction de
l'entreprise qui nous reçoit bien sûr
quand je parle avec les responsables de
chez bug et quand je parle avec une
petite entreprise locale c'est pas du
tout le même discours euh chez bu c'est
une salle vraiment énorme ils ont une
une surface qui qui qui est proche des
800 m² par contre dans les autres
entreprises on fait des actions vraiment
plus ponctuell donc ça peut-être des
juste un peu un créneau par semaine soit
pour du fitness ou de l'encadrement de
course à ou même parfois des des
pratiques de massage donc on a vraiment
un éventail de possibilités tout ça pour
le bien-être du salarié et on arrive en
général à toucher entre 15 à 20 % des
salariés donc en terme de personnel
c'est c'est quand même assez conséquent
ENF vous n avez toujours pas dit combien
ça pouvait coûter à l'entreprise c'estàd
est-ce qu'elle elle est prête à mettre
beaucoup de voilà un ordre d'idée alors
sincèrement c'est pas que je veux pas
vous donner de chiffre c'est que il n'y
a pas de chiffres par exemple mon plus
gros client aujourd'hui c'est EDF vous
avez parlé juste avant des Jeux
Olympiques et bien en fait avec EDF
j'envoie 85 coach sportifs entre le mois
de juillet et mois d'août pour encadrer
des activités sur le centre de vacances
donc ça c'est mon plus gros chiffre
d'affaires à l'année et en fait on parle
tout tout l'été on a un light motive un
fil conducteur c'est la candidature des
Jeux olympiques de 2024 donc on fait
faire du sport aux gens on fait de la
mise en forme ou de la remise en forme
pour ceux qui ont oublié ce que c'était
de faire du sport et on fait ça sous le
sous couvert de avec une une privé joke
de on se prépare pour les Jeux
Olympiques d'accord on sait bien que les
salariés ne se préparent pas pour les je
olympiques mais même c'est motivver et
mettre dans la tête que il y a un
événement majeur qui est qui est prévu
en France on est candidat et on mobilise
un petit peu les troupes pour que tout
le monde soit derrière la France et puis
en plus avec les Jeux olympiques de Rio
ça peut les motiver encore plus
évidemment alors marie-élèine caravantes
vous aussi vous vous travaillez avec les
entreprises puisque c'est vous qui
accueillez le le trophée des entreprises
alors comment ça se passe et pourquoi
vous avez décidé de participer à cette
aventure alors le site s'y prête
effectivement accueillir des entreprises
en plein air avec une course à pied bik
and activité nautique et et une course
d'orientation évidemment que ça ne
pouvait se dérouler que sur le site de
l'île de loisir euh donc c'est un
événement majeur effectivement de de
l'année où toutes les entreprises se
retrou une majorité d'entreprises se
retrouvent sur sur l'île de loisirs pour
effectivement partager ce moment ce
moment entre guillemets de compétition
parce que c'est une épreuve qui est
quand même accessible à à tout public et
donc c'est ça qui fait effectivement la
force de de de cette de ce trophée des
entreprises et est-ce que c'est une une
opération qui vous vous permet aussi et
non seulement de d'avoir une notoriété
là encore une fois on comprend mais
est-ce que ça vous permet aussi de de de
gagner de l'argent vraiment ou pas alors
j'irais pas jusqu'à dire à gagner de
l'argent en tout cas c'est effectivement
euh un un événement qui nous permet
d'avoir de la visibilité effectivement
sur les entreprises du territoire et
au-delà donc effectivement des
entreprises viennent ensuite organiser
voilà pour organiser des séminaires Team
Building et
autres développ juste avant l'émission
fitness Academy remporte très souvent
l'épreuve parce que non seulement vous
les entraînez c'est ça mais en plus vous
participez c'est un peu injuste quand
même vous êtes très fort est-ce que
c'est injuste je ne sais pas mais en
tout cas on participe à cet événement
effectivement depuis maintenant plus de
5 ans et l'idée c'est de rendre cet
événement complètement festif pour les
entreprises donc c'est absolument pas
l'idée de gagner ou pas notre on a une
équipe qui est vraiment forte au niveau
des féminines effectivement mais par par
contre l'équipe masculine est très
souvent enfin très très très loin de
nous parce que quand il s'agit de courir
ou de faire du vélo ça va très bien
après quand on arrive à l'orientation ou
à du canoé alors là c'est panique à bord
pourier encadrant et c'est assez drôle
donc nous nous nous occupons chaque
année de l'échauffement des 5 des pardon
des 500 personnes qui sont présentes
effectivement donc c'est très festif et
après les participants se font un
plaisir de ridiculiser nos encadrants
donc il leur ils les ont échauffé mais
par contre quand ils se retrouvent sur
un canoé alors là il y a plus personne
d'accord alors h vous alors vous vous
développez fait ce contact avec les
entreprises vous vous nous avez touché
de mots au début de cette émission avec
les séminaires parce qu'en fait ce
vélodrome il faut le faire vivre à
l'année c'est ça le l'ambition tout à
fait en fait c'est que nous on a trois
trois volets en fait on a les activités
quotidiennes sportives avec les gens qui
viennent tous les jours rouler faire du
badminton faire de la boxe on a en plus
de ça donc l'événementiel les
championnat d'Europe et d'autres
d'autres événements qu'on va faire on on
a accueil du judo on a envie
d'accueillir aussi de la partie
culturelle et sur la partie entreprise
là par contre c'est quasiment ce qui
nous permet de vivre au quotidien en
fait on a entre 1 à deux séminaires par
semaine et on développe beaucoup
l'activité donc soit en version dans une
petite salle où on peut accueillir entre
200 et 300 personnes soit en réservant
complètement l'air central on privatise
le vélodrome comme d'autres comme par
Mercedes skadaa ou McDonald's sont venus
et là on peut accueillir 2000 personnes
dans l'air centrale et on fait une
privatisation avec soit des activités en
plus même pour les petits ou pour les
grands on fait des baptêmes on fait
parfois du BMX parfois on est en
partenariat avec l'île de loisir on
était aussi partenaire en fait des
trophé entreprises et on a aussi une
équipe qui a couru en fait donc on est
tous assez proche on essaie de de céer
ou de de développer ensemble toute cette
partie là donc et donc les les
entreprises viennent beaucoup reviennent
en fait et donc après il faut leur
fournir des choses donc quand ils ont
fait des batès de piste quand ils ont
fait du BMX il faut leur fournir
d'autres activités donc parfois ils
peuvent faire des activités dans la base
de loisir ils peuvent aussi nous on a on
essaie de trouver d'autres partenaires à
côté donc là-dessus c'est vraiment
important de mélanger à la fois le parti
business où on va présenter on va faire
des plinières ou des des team building
la motivation et à côté faire une
activité ludique parce que les gens
après dans ce type d'événement il faut à
côté duud et à côté festif aussi en plus
du travail en fait d'ailleurs vous allez
accueillir le premier Sky Business Day
qui sera organisé le 13 octobre on y
reviendra dans la seconde partie de
cette émission parce que c'est vraiment
un des temps forts de la rentrée alors
justement nous allons maintenant voir
les points forts et les points faibles
du territoire avec le directeur de
France Miniature qui est l'une des des
attractions touristiques du territoire
écoutez Fabrice Watz aujourd'hui nos
visiteurs ils veulent un peu plus touché
ils veulent du ludique un peu plus
d'interactif donc c'est ce qu'on
développe depuis de 3 ans en apportant
toujours en racontant un petit morceau
de la France mais non plus par les
maquettes mais par des ateliers ludiques
interactifs au port de Marseille vous
avez une grue des containers vous
déplacez les containers ça vous raconte
un petit peu l'activité du port de
Marseille vous manipulez un barrage vous
manipulez une écluse voilà non plus du
loisir contemplatif mais du loisir
interactif notre clientèle elle se
développe soit soit en
B2B par les associations par les comités
d'entreprise les mairies on cherche
également à des assoation de personnes
du 3è âge je vous disais on vient à
France Miniature en famille on peut
aussi venir avec ses avec ses
grands-parents ou alors par le biais de
l'affichage et différents moyens de
communication auprès du du grand public
un petit peu plus directement une autre
particularité de France Miniature c'est
la visite scolaire on a un fort succès
au niveau des des sorties scolaires l'an
dernier je un peu plus de 20000
visiteurs sont venus avec l'école à
France Miniature on a à la fois le un
avantage et un point faible d'être
suffisamment éloigné de Paris pour avoir
cette image de campagne et être éloigné
du bruit et de la folie parisienne mais
on touche un premier niveau de transport
en commun un petit peu léger pour
attirer les grands flux de touristes qui
n'ont pas qui n'ont pas de voiture
aujourd'hui l'image de 50 ans nvenine
elle est d'un point de vue touristique
elle est peut-être encore un un petit
peu faible d'un point de vue tourisme
d'affaires d'un point de vue business
c'est une très belle destination d'un
point de vue tourisme c'est un petit peu
c'est un petit peu juste le le la grande
image de tourisme dans le 78 c'est
versaill voilà Versailles alors comment
concurrencer Versailles le roi soleil
c'est vrai que c'est un peu complexe
est-ce que vous êtes d'accord à ce qui
avec ce qui vient d'être dit déjà sur le
fait que le côté touristique est un
petit peu fragile encore et qu'il faut
le consolider est-ce que c'est un peu
votre mission qui va réagir à cela B
écoutez nous on fait tout ce qu'on peut
pour atteir des touristes avec des
événements internationaux en fait donc
là aujourd'hui on est les championnats
d'Europe après on a j'espère des on
négocie avec deux com deux promoteurs
anglais pour faire venir des courses sur
piste qui sont reconnu au niveau de
l'Europe entière et on a ils ont on a
déjà des demandes en fait de de
touristes anglais qui vont venir donc on
développe le territoire à ce niveau-là
en faisant que en c'est pas le brexit
non bah il y a eu enfin quand j'ai eu le
promoteur au téléphone non il y a pas il
y a pas eu de conséquence ils ont quand
même il son ils sont posés des questions
savoir s'ils devent faaire ou pas leur
business plan et savoir s'il dev venir
ou pas en France et voir ce qu'on
comment on peut avancer don ils ont dit
non on continue mais après aujourd'hui
voilà on les fait venir sur le
territoire après charge au territoire de
pouvoir accueir d'autres activités s'ils
sont là ils pourront aller faire un tour
sur la base de loisir ils pouront aller
faire un tour sur le golf et inversement
en fait donc en terme de et puis après
ils peuvent ausser faire un tour à
versaill et puis revenir c'est pas non
plus un problème en temps a priori les
transports est-ce qu'ils soi assez assez
présent parce que voilà le on écout par
du CO par exemple le coio ils sont venus
en transport en commun en fait le membre
qui est en train de travailler sur la
sur le coio ils ont mis 10 minutes ENF
12 minutes de la gare pour venir
jusqu'au mélodrome ça leur posait pas de
problème ils ont dit B écoutez c'est
très bien c'était plutôt bien fléché
donc il y avait pas de souci ils ont dit
peut-être que pendant les Jos on mettra
on va bloquer des rues pour être sûr que
le public soit mieux enfin le flux de
public soit un peu mieux
d'AC minutesenir à pied moi je suis allé
au championnat du monde de Londres en
fait de cyclisme sur piste en terme de
de comment d'éloignement du du
centreville de Londres et du Vélodrome
on est à peu près en même distance en
fait après c'est le Grand Londres
forcément mais là on est dans le Grand
Paris en fait donc il y a pas de souci
en terme de d'accessibilité ça pose pas
de problème Marie-Hélène caravant vous
êtes d'accord avec ça oui oui tout à
fait aujourd'hui on a un site qui est
accessible accessible en transport en
commun accessible en voiture donc il n'y
a plus qu'à a effectivement développer
cet axe touristique qui qui trouvera qui
trouvera sa place il y a il y a nous
avons effectivement tout toutes les
composantes pour pour développer cet
aspect touristique donc là c'est pour le
côté transport il y a aussi le côté
hôtelier c'est vrai que parfois ça peut
être un peu compliqué d'attirer une
clientèle internationale surtout au vu
de tout ce qui s'est passé en 2015 en
France avec les attentat notamment
comment la comment l'hôtellerie résiste
en cette période estivale F Bourdillon a
mené l'enquête
regardez merci beaucoup isab dans cette
auberge de luxe de Montini le Bretonneux
les clients étrangers sont choyés cette
année ils se sont fait plutôt RAR une
déception pour cette gérante qui pensait
engendrer une hausse de son chiffre
d'affaires de 30 % avec l'effet Euro
2016 du mois de juin sur l'euro on a
absolument eu aucun on a eu très très
peu de réservation par rapport à ça très
très peu du fait que il y a eu les
attentats du fait qu'il y a eu les
grèves du fait que au niveau image
internationale on a quand même beaucoup
souffert et puis les étrangers ont eu
peur je veux dire donc
forcément ça a impacté Paris et du coup
ça nous a impacté parce que logiquement
quand quand Paris travaille très très
bien au niveau touristique nous on a
toujours des retombées Isabelle fait
désormais appel à des tours opérateurs
et pour attirer une clientèle étrangère
et fam ac est mis sur une cuisine
franaise de qualité pour les étrangers
généralement c'est c'est important pour
eux ils aiment bien avoir plusieurs
desserts goûter que ça soit frais un peu
exotique à quelques kilomètres l'enjeu
est totalement différent pour cet hôtel
implanté au milieu d'une zone d'activité
la proximité de grandes sociétés leur
permet d'être souvent complet du
dimanche au jeudi soir la semaine
effectivement on a une clientèle 100 %
d'affaires et comment ça se passe alors
les weekends alors les weekends très
calme on essaie d'attirer une clientèle
de loisirs mais on a un petit peu de mal
on avait une clientèle étrangère qui
venait dans notre établissement les
weekends mais suite aux attentats qu'il
y a eu elle ne vient plus avec l'arrivée
des vacances scolaires l'activité
hôtelière diminue fortement dans
l'agglomération pour rester attractif
cet hôtel propose des promotions sur les
chambres allant jusqu'à 50 % en
attendant une reprise de l'activité à la
rentrée voilà al est-ce que cette offre
hôtélière est à la hauteur de bah du
sport enfin de tout ce que vous allez
proposer des événements qui sont qui
sont prévus hugaro ben oui écoutez nous
on est on a justement des des hôtels du
du territoire qui sont partenaires du
Vélodrome le groupe Louvre hôtel en fait
avec des campagnî qui sont juste à côté
en fait donc on développe avec eux des
offres pour les événements et puis aussi
pour les séminaires après on a d'autres
hôtels qui sont construits juste à côté
du Vélodrome donc aujourd'hui l'offre
commence à à s'étaufer on travaille bien
après c'est plus les événements sont
importants forcément il y a peut-être
des problèmes mais aujourd'hui vous êtes
très on vous sort trèsine vousê pr il
faut aujourd'hui il faut il faut faut
surtout être motivé et surtout pas se
démotiver et faire en sorte de de de
croire à ce bâtiment et à développer
comment avec tous les événs qu'on va
pouvoir accueillir ouais vous allez même
accueillir des concerts ce qui est voà
pas mal un petit marieine caravant vous
vous leur faites de la concurrence avec
donc ce camping vous allez accueillir
combien de personnes dans ce camping
alors on serait sur un camping avec 4
400 plus de 400 emplacements hein donc
tout type de d'hébergement Lodge enfin
en tout cas qui peut être offert sur un
un camping air de campingc et là ça
répond en partie au aux cyclistes qui
viennent s'entraîner aux cyclistes qui
viennent effectivement sur les
compétitions BMX particulièrement donc
campingcar tente et puis des lodges
effectivement on serait sur un camping 4
étoiles qui ouvre donc qui euh ouvrirait
euh 2017 2017 parfait vous serez prêt
pour la rider Cup donc voilà on vous le
souhaite ce magnifique campingor votre
priorité à vous en tant que président
Directeur de de fitness Académie et bien
en fait tout a été résumé nous sommes à
25 km de Paris donc c'est un formidable
avantage et c'est un formidable
inconvénient c'est que les gens qui
viennent à Paris effectivement qui qui
viennent voir la tour effffel ou même le
château de Versailles bien est-ce qu'ils
peuvent pousser jusqu'à 51 Lig c'est pas
toujours facile mais par contre nous
avons l'avantage d'être suffisamment
loin d'être de de Paris pour être à la
campagne donc en terme de pratique
sportive et bien il y a des étents il y
a des grandes étendues il y a un
vélodrome un golf une base de loisir
extraordinaire donc on a les avantages
de ces inconvénients et en terme de
d'entreprise puisque je me place sur le
point de vue business et bien pour nous
c'est une formidable richesse donc on
propose aux entreprises effectivement de
l'accompagnement en extérieur donc pour
les salariés pour leur apprendre à
marcher puis à trottiner puis
éventuellement les accompagner sur sur
une première course de 6 6 km puis
éventuellement jusqu'à un semi ou un
marathon carrément alors là en terme
d'infrastructure c'est parfait pour nous
merci à vous trois d'avoir participé à
ce fil éch alors merci grâce à vous on
s'est un peu échauffé pour la seconde
partie de cette émission je vous
souhaite un très bel été sportif
évidemment festif aussi nous allons
maintenant voir la revue de presse
économique la revue web préparée par
Fannie Bourdillon
[Musique]
50 ans en Yveline voit sa note relevée
par Standard and pours un an après avoir
confirmé les bonnes notes de
l'agglomération l'agence de notation
vient de la relever à AA Mo soulignant
ainsi la bonne gestion du territoire
Versailles se rêve en pôle culturel du
Grand Paris selon les échos en plus du
château le festival de théâtre et de
musique le Mois Molière qui se déroule
chaque année en juin et le faire de
lance de la politique culturel de la
ville la commune souhaite devenir
l'Oxford français renforcé par la
concurrence de 50 ans en yeline la ville
nouvelle qui possède depuis le début des
années 90 un théâtre au statut de scène
nationale se voit bien aussi incarner le
renouveau culturel dans le département
le 78 actu revient sur le livre blanc
remis à Nicolas Sarkozi le mercredi 29
juin génération entreprise continue son
combat pour les sociétés Olivier d'assau
et Jean-Michel Fourgous lui ont remis 20
propositions économiques pour relancer
la croissance selon le maire d'lancour
rien qu'avec ces mesures vous pouvez
avoir de points de croissance et sauver
ce
[Musique]
pays vive vacances donc mais la rentrée
et bien il faut la préparer alors quels
sont les grands événements économiques
qui nous attendent les grands dossiers
de 2016-207 et bien nous allons en
parler avec nos invités que vous
connaissez Jean-Michel Fourgous bonjour
bonjour alors vous êtes maire d'élancour
vous êtes aussi vice président de la
Communauté d'Agglomération de 50 ans en
Yveline dans le secteur économique à vos
côté Jean-Luc Meron vous êtes directeur
de la Maison de l'Entreprise de 5 an
Éveline merci d'être avec nous et enfin
y Foucher al vous êtes le président de
la Fondation UVSQ et vous êtes aussi
celui qui présidait à cette plateforme
initiative plateforme pour financer les
entreprises on va en parler dans un
instant vous n'êtes pas en vacances
bonjour vous n'êtes pas en vacances
puisque vous êtes avec nous donc sur TV
fil 78 pour filcho alors Gan Michel
Fourgous peut-être une petite réaction à
cette annonce positive de standard
handpour j'imagine que vous êtes
satisfait mais écoutez ça correspond à
notre volonté de rupture culturelle
euh donc avec l'économie omie
aujourd'hui les dirigeants des
structures publiques puisque la cas ski
ou ski c'est l'état de proximité donc on
souhaite inverser cette culture bien
montrer qu'on est proche des entreprises
que l'on est à l'écoute des gens qui
font la richesse un de ce pays qui
payent les écoles qui payent les routes
qui payent les hôpitaux ce sont les
entreprises et aujourd'hui l'État de
proximité doit être un exemple donc on
veut être un exemple de ces bonnes
pratiques de cette nouvelle attitude
vis-à-vis de l'entreprise on est à son
service il faut arrêter de donner des
leçons de morale toute la journée l'État
n'a pas il a son rôle certes mais mais
il faut vraiment qu'aujourd'hui on soit
un accompagnateur un partenaire et non
pas à juger à être punitif à être voilà
donc la casquie c'est c'est l'exemple de
cette nouvelle gestion on est beaucoup
plus à l'écoute des des des règles de
l'économie il faut d'abord faire réussir
l'économie avant de parler de
redistribution on commence à produire la
richesse et donc là on inverse la façon
de gérer la casquie et c'est et on est
passé de 1a à 2A alors qu'en ce moment
même l'Angleterre voyez a perdu son son
TR mê on va pas les plainre alors voilà
enfin voilà ça c'est dit donc euh
justement pour accompagner ces
entreprises il y a donc cette cette
structure qui va ouvrir en novembre une
structure que vous avez tous accompagné
soutenu donc c'est le Sky cuube euh
Jean-Michel Fourgous bon on va je vais
vous reposer la question mais vous aussi
vous allez nous en parler effectivement
euh que va proposer Sky cuube qu'est-ce
que vous proposez avec cette structure
que nous voyons ici à l'écran alors euh
déjà donc nous c'est vraiment
l'évolution culturelle comme je vous
disais pour pour pour s une PA et euh en
septembre vous avez un événement par
pour les étudiants ça commence en en
mélangeant les cultures d'ingénieurs et
de d'université avec c'est ce grand
projet aussi de de l'Université Paris
SACL qui arrive bon qui qui qui doit
demain devenir 19e au classement de
Shangai alors qu'on est 45e actuellement
donc VO pour septembre ensuite bien sûr
en octobre vous avez d'autres événements
en novembre effectivement l'ouverture de
de de de de donc de cet incubateur de
nouvelles génération puisque là il
s'agit d'abord ça nous a coûté quand
même 3 millions d'investissement bon
pour 20 start-up ensuite environ ça nous
coûter environ 300000 € de
fonctionnement voyez pour une 20 20
jeunes cré d'entreprise donc il s'agit
d'avoir un environnement extrêmement
stimulateur un accélérateur d'innovation
dans leur tête un accélérateur de bonnes
pratiqu de formation donc ils auront
accès bien sûr aux meilleures
informations aux meilleures formations
et aux meilleurs partenaires également
partenaires financier d'ailleurs dont
vous allez parlé tout à l'heure donc
c'est quand même c'est quand même un un
un vivier de de stimulation un
accélérateur également de de prospect
puisque vous avez en en octobre aussi un
accélérateur de de prospect de contact
vous verrez sur une belle manifestation
peutêre par dans dans quelques minutes
on l'a équé pu le Sky business day je
pense voilà on en a parlé puisque ça va
se passer au Vélodrome iloucher à mot de
de ce sky cube on parlait du financement
le financement ça ça passe aujourd'hui
par cette plateforme est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en toucher un mot surtout
vous avez développé maintenant il y aura
du crwfunding aussi comment ça ça va
marcher va y avoirir al aujourd'hui il
effectivement une plateforme qui
distribu euh des prêtsdonneurs c'estàd
qui distribu des prêts à des personnes
physiques associées dans des structures
que ces personnes créent des start-ups
et ou ou des des des activités
économiques plus simples euh et la
plateforme va très très bien puisque
depuis le le début de l'année 2016 sur
le prier semestre on a près de 60 % de
progression en nombre de de de crédit
accordés euh on est pas loin de de 50
dossiers qui sont clos positivement clos
euh c'est plus de 500000 € de prês euh
et surtout au-delà de ces 500000 € de
prê c'est aussi 1300000 € de prêt
bancairees qui viennent s'additionner au
fait qu'on a bien voulu financer ces ces
créateurs ou ses développeurs
d'entreprise donc la plateforme va très
bien l'économie cantinoise va très bien
tant mieux on s'en félicite euh ceux qui
vont intégrer skyq par exemple est-ce
qu'ils auront une une écoute plus
attentive de votre part pour financer
leur projet je il y a pas de privilège
au fait d'avoir l'honneur et l'avantage
d'être hébergé dans le skycube nous la
plateforme on est là financé par la
communauté de saint-canttinvine
d'ailleurs pour aider des créateurs ou
des développeurs d'entreprise donc
évidemment il y a un immense intérêt à
trouver des start-up qui sont dans
l'innovation dans l'innovation
technologique mais pas que donc ils
seront accueillis aussi favorablement
que les autres dès lors que les projets
auront été validés mais j'imagine que
s'ils sont accueillis dans skycube c'est
que les projets sont d'intérêt sont
solides et peuvent aboutir à plus de
pérénité et puis une fois qu'ils seront
sortis de l'incubateur ils viendront
peut-être à Promopole et et ainsi de
suite donc donc la plateforme de
financement si il dépose des projets et
des demandes ces demandes seront
étudiées et au-delà comme vous
l'évoquez donc là je peux pas donner la
date exae à ce jour et je laisserai
JeanMichel le faire mais on est
clairement on avait évoqué cette
hypothèi oui oui mais on avait évoqué
cette hypothèse aujourd'hui c'est plus
un projet c'est une réalité nous avons
conclu un accord avec K invest pour le
dire qui est une plateforme existante
qui va nous développer une structure en
marque blanche parce que le le Crone
c'est c'est pas si simple il faut un
agrément de
laamf l'Autorité des marchés financiers
on peut pas se se lancer comme ça donc
ça nous a permis de de d'accélérer les
processus d'avoir un outil qui marche et
donc dès le mois de septembre octobre
sur 50 heeline à destination des
entreprises de 50 he neline au-delà des
prêts qui sont consenti par la
plateforme jusqu'à à peu près 50000 €
cette plateforme de crowdfunding en
equity comme on dit en jargon
c'est-à-dire en apport en capital ou
aussi en prêt qui pourra aller de ces
50000 € jusqu'à 1 million d'euros 1
million d'euros faudra être convaincant
mais pourquoi pas pourquoi pas il y a de
grandes entreprises qui autour que
s'appelle Tales qu'elle s'appelle Airbus
sont prêtes ces grandes entreprises à
financer des jeunes entreprises qui les
aideront aussi à développer avec elle
des outils donc faut pas on n'est pas
dans le domaine du rêve d'ailleurs entre
eneur peut rêver mais juste le weekend
parce que pendant la semaine vaut mieux
être pragmatique aprs il faêtre voilà
très réaliste et voilà il mettre les
mains dans le Comou comme on dit donc y
a donc ce ce crwfunding qui va se mettre
en place skycube Jean-Luc mer vous
comment ça va justement fonctionner les
liens entre la visison de l'entreprise
le skycube Promopole expliquez-nous un
peu concrètement pour ces 20 créateurs
d'entreprise qu'est-ce qui va se passer
Jean-Michel fourgousse le soulligne à
l'instant donc somes dans une logique de
structure partenariale et et le mot est
important parce que l'idée de de ce
projet initialement c'était de donner du
sens aux actions comm m le territoire et
puis mettre en
en dans une articulation intelligente
tous les acteurs qui gravite autour de
la création du développement
d'entreprise il Foucher également
souligné la la logique de parcours
résidentiel en en citant Promopole tout
à l'heure euh vraiment notre volonté au
travers de ce projet c'est de faire en
sorte que les entreprises voient la
enfin a une vraie lisibilité l'ensemble
des dispositifs qui pourront les
accompagn dans leur phase de création de
développement au travers du financement
mais entre autres au travers du
financement et puis également dans leur
phase de développement donc nous sommes
nous en tant qu'acteur public puisque ce
projet skycube est porté par la la
communauté d'agglomération dans
l'obligation de rendre justement lisible
et complémentaire t tous ces dispositifs
faire en sorte qu'ils soit optimisé et
tout ça pour que les entreprises voilà
il voient très clair et puis puissent
utiliser à bon éent tous les tous les
dispositifs qu'on mettra à leur
disposition alors les entreprises les
grands groupes comme vous le disiez
elles sont ils sont partants voilà et
comment ils vont faire à ce que il aura
des tuteurs est-ce qu'il y a des
personnes qui sont déléguées à à
travailler avec ces ces jeunes créateurs
est-ce qu'ils vont les financer est-ce
qu'ils vont leur comment ça va se passer
concrètement pour qu'on comprenne un peu
le Sky cube qu'est-ce que ça va apporter
à ces à ces créateurs chez for ben de
mettre des gens en réseau st très
important quand vous créez une
entreprise si on vous met dans un réseau
dynamique avec des des gros bien sûr il
est évident qu'à 50 ans on a la chance
on n pas on est à 30 minutes de Paris
vous le savez c'est en feu rouge en
dehors des dans bien sûr euh c'est c'est
voilà vous avez des très belles
entreprises françaises et
internationales les meilleurs des très
beaux laboratoires d'idées des bon
également universités qui dem peut
devenir la 19e université au monde bon
donc voilà vous avez un vivier
extrêmement dynamique donc de mettre ces
créateurs d'entreprise ces start-up dans
ce vivier c'est très stimulant quand
vous êtes avec des gens qui ont déjà un
niveau d'information sur la
mondialisation c'est un accélérateur de
réussite pour vous donc c'est très
important de les mettre dans dans ces
réseaux ça je nul doute je voulais
savoir s'il y avait effectivement des
gens au sein des des grandes entrepris
qui étent délégé qui vont qui vont être
au Sky cube pour justement informer ces
jeunes créateurs ou comment concrètement
cette relation seée alors on prévoit à
partir de septembre et on onche
quelqu'un de complémentaire aussi bon
sur une fonction de direction générale
adjointe mais qui a cette grande
expérience de de ce qu'on appelle les
passerelles c'est-à-dire de stimuler une
entreprise bien sûr à à certains de ces
cadres qui veulent se lancer dans dans
dans l'aventure euh individuel
entrepreneurial de les stimuler et en
fait on a aussi ce plan donc d'accélérer
ces ces rapprochements ces liens entre
les gros les petits de toute façon elle
est là la dynamique et à Saint-Quentin
comme on est très bien classé on a quand
même le le 2uxè PIB par habitant le plus
élevé après après après Paris bien sûr
que c'est un vivier extraordinaire donc
de de c'est c'est c'est plus facile de
faire de l'émulation comme ça entre les
gros et les petits quand on a la chance
d'avoir des gens de qualité comme ça
donc tout le monde va en profiter de ça
mais il faut accélérer encore cela et
vous avez déjà choisi ces jeunesfin je
entrepreneurs qui vont intégrer le
skycuub comment ils ont été choisis
est-ce que c'est fait ou pas ou est-ce
qu'on peut encore acter alors si vous
voulez être très professionnel bah Vous
vous fa faut prendre ce qu'il y a de
mieux dans la vie alors quand on peut
parce que aussi une question de moyen
mais on a la chance d'avoir quand même
de pouvoir avir un peu ce ce qu' donc on
prend le meilleur spécialiste français
me demandez pas lequel parce qu'il est
en attribution donc j'ai pas le droit de
vous le dire c'est des attributions de
marché mais on on on on se prépare à
prendre Quême un des meilleurs sur le
marché pour suivre cet incubateur pour
nous aider à sélectionner sur
SaintQuentin et nous aider à gérer hein
donc et accompagner et à donner toutes
les prestations de service les
meilleures pour que ces 20 soient je pas
que demain il y a un marcel d'asso qui
sorte il a créé qume plusieurs centaines
de millions d'emplois que ce soit un bug
ou que ce soit un deco ou ou autre il y
a mais il faut il faut savoir fertiliser
les talents et sa- Quentin doit être un
fertilisateur de talent au niveau des
universités qu'on essaie de faire bouger
au niveau de tous les servic nouveau au
niveau de de Promopole qui le deuxième
étage quand vous avez réussi à
l'incubateur hop vous passez à Promopole
parce que quand vous devenez un peu plus
gros bah oui c'est là et puis
troisièmement on a un service 3è étage
après de de donner des locaux qui sont
adaptés au taille que que vous avez
besoin si vous avez
besoin de 1000 m² ou si vous av 100 m²
c'est pas la même chose donc ici il y a
trois trois niveaux de suivi pour bien
accompagner la la montée en puissance de
ces jeunes qu'on va sélectionner donc
bientôt avec cette société auquelle on
est en train de choisir le marché voilà
fusée à trois étages donc on suivra ça
avec attention le Sky cuube d'ailleurs
je suis sûr qu'on va faire beaucoup de
reportages sur son inauguration et après
sur son fonctionnement on a hâte de
découvrir ses futurs et la région la
région d'ailleurs est et à priori nous
accompagne aussi dans ce projet aussi
alors maintenant on va s'intéresser à un
autre grand projet qui intervient un peu
plus tard puisque c'est en octobre le
Skype business day c'est la première
édition donc là aussi peut-être je pense
que vous êtes tous très au courant de ce
cet événement qui va réunir vraiment
tout le enfin les ça00 entreprises du
territoire si je ne m'abuse et là aussi
c'est vraiment se mettre en réseau les
les différents acteurs économiques il
fouch que vous voulez un mot de cette
grande initiative qui est prévue au
Vélodrome volontier à souci pas que je
n'en suis pas l'organisateur mais je
pense que c'est une très bonne
initiative parce que on le dit depuis
qu'on discute ensemble là rien ne marche
autrement qu'en réseau euh à tel point
que même sur un territoire comme 50 en
niveline qui maintenant est un
territoire important près de 150000
emplois surtout avec le territoire a
grandi il y a des milliers d'entreprises
les plus grandes j'en ai cité deux
d'ailleurs je voudrais pas que les
autres imaginent que je les ai oublié il
y a les plus grands groupes français sur
50 an000 et il y a aussi une immensité
de petites et moyennes entreprises dans
tous les domaines d'activité mais qui ne
se connaissent pas toujours et qui
pourraiit faire du business de proximité
mais qui ben ne se rencontrre pas
forcément et ce type de manifestation
précisément et de nature à favoriser
accélérer ces processus de de de
rencontrre et donc de partenariat et
puis j'ajouterais puisqu'on évoqué les
partenaires et que vous avez la
gentillesse de dire que cétait président
de la Fondation de l'Université de
Versailles Saint-Quentin l'université de
Versailles saint-qutin est aussi un
partenaire de tous ces opérations parce
que je pense qu'il faut développer
l'envie d'entreprendre au sein de
l'université pardon il faut commencer
tôt
c'estàdi il faut d'ailleurs faut
commencer bien avant l'université à mon
avis dès l'école faut expliquer que une
entreprise c'est c'est un lieu de vie
c'est un lieu de de recherche c'est un
lieu de succès c'est un lieu de partage
c'est un lieu parfois difficile mais
mais c'est avant tout là qu'on crée de
la richesse donc moi j'essaie de le
faire à l'université j'essaie de
rapprocher l'Université des des des
entreprises et avec le le président
guimot le le nouveau président de
l'université il a décidé de poursuivre
la Fondation donc on va continuer et se
rapprocher de Saint-Quentin et se
rapprocher également de l'incubateur
parce que je suis convaincu que au sein
de l'université de Versailles sa-quentin
il y a les pépites de demain mais il
faut expliquer aux chercheurs qui l'ont
compris mais il faut encore développer
le fait qu'ils aient envie de créer des
entreprises ou il y a déjà quand même
beaucoup de rendez-vous qui sont
organisés dans ce cadre là effectivement
celui-ci va encore un peu plus loin il
est-être encore plus ambitieux Jean-Luc
Mirot vous vu que vous dirigez la Maison
de l'Entreprise est-ce que vous sentez
cette cette demande des entreprises
est-ce qu' elles vous en font pas
comment vous voyez ça oui bien sûr
d'abord on est sur un territoire qui est
très riche en entreprise avec de très
grand compte on en parle régulièrement
mais aussi beaucoup de de PME TPE qui
ont besoin d'avoir des contacts
privilégiés avec ces grandes entreprises
qui elles parfois méconnaissent un peu
le tissu économique local donc d'abord
cette édition est la première édition
euh donc c'est une opération qui est
nouvelle pour pour le territoire vous
évoquez tout à l'heure le nombre de 500
c'est effectivement le nombre l'objectif
que que nous nous fixons pour pour cette
première édition mais pour commencer à
communiquer autour de cette opération et
échanger avec nombre de dirigeants
d'entreprise euh c'est une opération qui
est très attendue et on espère vraiment
qu'elle connaîtra un vive succès alors
Jean-Michel fourgos on avait déjà la
grande soirée des entrepreneurs qui
était à rendez-vous pour les
entrepreneurs vraiment on sent et vous
l'avez bien expliqué encore une fois
qu'il faut les mettre en avant qu'est-ce
que vous attendez de ce sky business day
ben c'est c'est d'abord il y a près de
400 entreprises qui sont ciblé bon euh
donc voilà de de Saint-Quentin
deuxièmement ça c'est c'est vous savez
lui c'est un accélér ateur de
financement il a ce rôle voilà il a la
compétence voilà Jean-Luc c'est un
accélérateur de de de service autour de
de de l'entrepreneur bon après vous sais
je suis un ancien chercheur CNRS
jeentreise j'ai vu les difficultés bon à
un momentné pour réussir c'est les
prospects il faut il faut améliorer la
qualité de vos prospects mieux les
cibler donc c'est le but de cette
manifestation Sky business day bon le
journée la journée des affaires en tout
cas à Saint-Quentin dire bon c'est être
un accélérateur de contact commerciaux
de prospect mieux ciblé parce que
souvent le jeune créateur d'entreprise
il il sait il voit tout le monde mais en
fait ilut il vaut mieux qu'il fasse que
c'est les 20 80 vous savez les 20 % de
de certains prospects il va il va il il
faut lui faire gagner du temps et c'est
le but aussi de ce service que que l'on
empl ce jour-là qui qui a fait ses
preuve donc voilà qu'est-ce qu'il y a de
plus mieux que que que d'accélér
d'accélérer la qualité des des échanges
commerciaux entre un jeune chef
d'entreprise et puis ou d'ailleurs un
entrepreneur génal et une grosse c'est
la rencontre entre les gros les petits
et puis mieux qualifié mieux qualifié le
rendez-vous ça ça vaut de l'or donc
c'est ce qu'on leur offre ce jourl donc
ça sera des rendez-vous comme des c'est
très à la mode en ce moment mais des
speed dating où il faut voilà c'est ça
chacun doit se se présenter proposer ses
voilà donc ça ça sera proposé à 400 mais
comme la soir des entrepreneurs vous
aviez des rencontres entre les gros et
les petits aussi parce que après il y
avait un cocktail pour qui parle ex cé
pas uniquement pour manger FO CIT pour
qu'ils échangent leur carte de vis et
qu'ils se connaissent et et et c'est
vrai que l'objectif pour l'instant c'est
de faire monter le PIB de 50 ans donc
quand vous êtes SaintQuentin quand vous
l'êtes bien entendu vous avez une
assistance une une un accompagnement de
haute qualité c'est la r du jeu alors il
faut je le rappeler il faut aller au
contact des des jeunes et des plus
jeunes alors on va juste parler d'abau
de la Maison de l'étudiant elle va être
inaugurée c'était important qui ait ce
lieu de vie pour pour les étudiants
c'est un temps fort de la rentrée oui
bien sûr mais là aussi euh
je je la vie de l'être humain c'est un
début un développement une fin et tous
les êtres humains ou presque en tout cas
la plupart d'entre eux vont à l'école à
l'université passent un long moment en
entreprise et puis après essaie de
profiter de la vie et la Maison de
l'étudiant c'est aussi le fait de de
s'inscrire dans ce parcours de vie et de
montrer que sur le territoire de
Saint-Quentin et ben on trouve à peu
près tout il y a pas besoin d'aller
chercher chché tellement ailleurs et que
c'est un des plus beau euh territoir de
de l'Île-de-France c'est un territoire
économique remarquablement développé
donc la maison d'étudiant ça va avec la
maison d'entreprise ça va avec
l'incubateur c'est cet ensemble de
produits disponi pour les
50tinois pour que ils réussissent leur
vie et qu'il vivent épanoui là je je
fais le boulot des politique de
Saint-Quentin mais je le fais volontiers
puisque puisque je crois dans
Saint-Quentin j'y travaille depuis près
de 30 ans donc je pense que c'est un
modèle remarquable très bien ben
Jean-Luc mud et Jean-Michel fourgos un
mot de de conclusion sur cette rentrée
qui s'annonce donc plutôt bien beaucoup
d'événements on en a cité un certain
nombre mais d'autres se tiendront sur
les thématiques de l'emploi l'immobilier
d'entreprise également qui aura un
moment fort au mois de de décembre donc
voilà nous sommes très actifs et nous
répondons à la demande des entreprises
en essayant d'anticiper leurs besoins en
tout cas c'est c'est le r c'est le rôle
du du la direction du développement
économique de de la communauté
d'agglomération donc Jean-Michel
Fourgous nous pouvons partir en vacances
l'esprit tranquille cette rentrée ça va
bien notre objectif c'est d'être l'état
inversé hein et de et de développer
vraiment en France une culture
entrepreneuriale de haute qualité on a
tous les atouts pour réussir et si on
fait cela je peux vous dire euh euh on
va résoudre le chômage on va résoudre le
problème du financement de nos retraites
voilà la seule condition c'est changer
de culture et d'adhérer à une culture
entrepreneale sans état d'âes plus
jamais voilà on a vécu des moments très
difficiles pendant 4 ans on ne veut plus
ces états d'âes euh euh l'approche une
fois on veut que ce soit que les
Français comprennent que la première
unité de solidarité c'est pas moi le
maire des lancour moi je crée pas la
richesse c'est eux donc il faut les
aider si on veut résoudre le problème du
chômage de la croissance c'est d'abord
comprendre que l'entreprise c'est la
première unité de solidarité de ce pays
voilà très bien merci messieur d'avoir
participé à ce filcho voilà on va suivre
avec attention tous ces grands
événements qui nous attendent à la
rentrée et maintenant notre agenda voilà
notre agenda puisque il y a un agenda
pour la
rentrée
avec déjà la semaine de la mobilité
c'est du 12 au 13 septembre 2016
Saint-Quentin en Eveline se met à
l'heure de la semaine européenne de la
mobilité objectif promouvoir les
transports en commun les modes
alternatifs à la voiture individuelle
plus d'informations sur le site
squanttineveline.fr et enfin on en a
beaucoup parlé dans cette émission et
pour cause le Sky business day on vous
en a beaucoup parlé je le disais c'est
la première édition le rendez-vous est
pris le 13 octobre 2016 au Vélodrome
nation et cette convention d'affaires
organisée par 550 anine vise à mettre en
lien les grands honneur d'ordre les
prestateurs locaux d'approcher de
nouveaux fournisseurs de nouveaux
clients c'est vraiment l'occasion de se
mettre tous en réseau donc retenez bien
cette date c'est le 13 octobre prochain
au Vélodrome national voilà pour la
rentrée d'ici là profitez quand même de
vos vacances sur le territoire ou
ailleurs faites du sport aller au
Vélodrome au golf national que vous
connaissez parfaitement j'imagine
messieurs filecho c'est terminé pour
aujourd'hui merci à vous de nous avoir
suivi VI on se retrouve très vite d'ici
là restez sur TVfil
[Musique]